all right there's a new company coming
to vegas that is ready to give you
culinary entertainment with major major
perks and it's all happening inside the
studio kitchen check this out
we're so excited to talk to you about
what you're bringing to las vegas things
are opening up and it is the perfect
time to add a new
brand new experience to our city so i
know you're a culinary entertainment
expert
and you're so successful in this so
let's just get a little background on
what you and your family have done
for the world so the studio kitchen is a
culinary entertainment company
we've actually been developing this for
15 years as a family business
so it started with a little idea we had
in boston in 2005
in which we had this restaurant a family
restaurant and we had this extra room
and for years in our restaurants we
would have guests
tell us after they met our chef i wish i
had asked a question i wish i had
asked that burning culinary question but
i was too intimidated
and so that sparked an idea that we
should break down this barrier
that people have with chefs with
culinary questions
and make it easy and and approachable to
learn about food
from masters so we started doing this
thing on friday nights where 12 people
from the restaurant would go into this
little room
and we would invite our chef from the
back kitchen in
and they would do a little demonstration
of the special of the night
15 years later we've added in cameras
and microphones and and
streaming and all sorts of multimedia
and now it's a standalone entertainment
company
where anyone can buy tickets get a four
course
meal with a wine pairing that's made by
a real master chef
and the whole time that the chef is
creating real food in front of you
you get to ask questions they encourage
you to ask questions and obviously house
of blues now studio kitchen you guys
belong in las vegas
and i think so i have to say i see the
amy's back there so i kind of feel like
the concept worked out for you
uh we've won four times we've actually
won twice for set design of the studio
kitchen
and now we're gonna take these 3 000
live shows we've done over
15 years come to the entertainment
capital of the world
and start a new company a studio kitchen
company
in las vegas and we're actually
welcoming all our former customers
our family our friends the las vegas now
community
to become our partners in this new
venture we're on a platform called start
engine which is the best in the business
anyone for as little as 300 on a credit
card
can buy shares of our company and in
addition to
owning shares alongside us founders
we're giving you tickets
you can uh name a seat in the studio and
get your name on a seat you can get a
private show
you can be a producer um so it's think
of it's like
a kickstarter indiegogo but instead of
just getting rewards you get ownership
and this is the new wave of the future
with investing it's democratizing
finance and letting everyone get in the
ground floor of startups
with founders what a concept okay well
we will keep
update we'll keep updating everybody
over the next year
until you the grand opening yeah yeah we
can't wait
we're hoping to open by the next summer
so then over next summer all the locals
can start feeling it out and then
we'll have a probably a big grand
opening uh next fall
as the conventions return and just all
the things are coming back to vegas
we're going to be a part of that all
right jc founding investor
this place looks awesome i know i know
i'm so excited okay you can become a
founding investor as well of the studio
kitchen just head to starting.com
studio kitchen and right now all
investors get at least two free tickets
and you heard them so many perks this is
so cool i'm gonna get my wallet yeah i'm
all in we'll be right back